[Applause]
written by canadian nia vardalis and
based on her one woman play the quiet
hit made 240 million domestic gross for
perspective the film was produced by tom
hanks and wife rita wilson for just five
million dollars i mean talk about a
profit
i would say that my real life family is
on a scale of one to ten they're about
an eleven and my real life wedding was
about a twelfth
and then i took all that i squished it
all into the screenplay and i turned it
up to twenty
i'm jealous of me it doesn't seem real
now that i tell it
it was an amazing moment in my
acting
kingdom
oh you're all oily
i'm greek now
because of its massive success came a tv
series my big fat greek life and a big
fat greek wedding too and e.t canada was
on set
we're all greek now oh and here's a
special guest my dad
hey
dad
he's only 39 dad does windex work on
everything yeah sure of course it works
your mom felt the same way about being
greek florida texas new york these are
the colleges i'm applying to why do you
want to leave me
payback
when i decided to write the sequel there
was no way i could do it without
bringing back the whole cast i love them
all so much they are an integral part of
a puzzle
even though i'm taking a step back i
will always be
right here